KUMAIL NANJIANI
In the beginning, there was nothing.
Even the Infinity Stones were
but the shadow of a dream.
Then, there was the first sun, galaxies,
and a bunch of other boring stuff...
And then, there was Kingo! Eternal
extraordinaire and giant movie star.
Pure of heart
and big of bicep, he...
Um... Sorry...
Did you say anything?
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Thank you.
Bestowed with powers far beyond
a mortal man, Kingo protects humanity
from evil Deviants, aided in his quest
by a revolving cast of sidekicks,
some of whom really...
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Wow...
SALMA HAYEK
Seriously, dude?
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Sidekicks... That is rich.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Oh! I was just making it my own!
SALMA HAYEK
Like everything! You make everything
your own!
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Sorry! Sorry! Assistants? Is that better?
Okay, I can see
that's not good. Helpers?
ANGELINA JOLIE
What's going on?
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Oh, you're gonna love this. Tell her.
SALMA HAYEK
Uh-huh.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
I... was...
SALMA HAYEK
What'd you say? Go on.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Angelina Jolie's not one of the sidekicks.
She's one of the main ones.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Okay.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Alright, alright! I'll start over.
Lemme, just...
Start over. Okay?
SALMA HAYEK
Please!
KUMAIL NANJIANI
In the beginning...
If you guys could not look at me,
it makes me very... Just...
SALMA HAYEK
Okay, we'll turn around
but she's got her weapons.
ANGELINA JOLIE
We're all gonna turn around.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Yeah, just turn around...
Thank you.